they have found that certain topics are
in but just really quick i think there's
no rules because they want you to be
paranoid they want you to censor
yourself they want you to be scared to
even dare they should accomplish
something that that could go against the
the grain or the establishment and i
think how about this 2098 i could lose
my license i'm scared [ __ ] and it's and
and
let it out drew it's a lot more sinister
than than just like hey let's let's try
to you know keep the rules here because
you look at what the what facebook was
doing with the fbi facebook was
colluding with them giving them
information spying on people getting
people's private messages but they also
did that with covet there's facebook
emails showing how zuckerberg was
offering dr fauci data on users to help
the lockdown policies to help people
make sure that they weren't going
outside of their homes facebook was
volunteering that information so the way
that they work together the way that
they collude is far more interconnected
than we even know about